Ich ... ja ... also ...
Ich bin froh,
es heute Abend zu erfahren.
Ich muss dringend
eine Aktivität finden,
damit ich nicht
zu viel darüber nachdenke.
Ich Bern fallen jetzt
die Entscheidungen:
Wer von diesen fünf
wird Diplomatin oder Diplomat?
Hold on! Are you at the Swiss club?
- C'est la, c'est la.
Este es mi machete,
Spickzettel, auf Deutsch.
Du bist Krisenmanager.
- Yes, are you here?
Yala, yala.
Diplomatie ist in der Schweiz
nicht besonders beliebt.
Man kennt uns nicht gut. Das ist
vielleicht auch unsere Schuld.
And a toast together.
(Ignazio Cassis) Auf Sie zählen wir
während der nächsten Jahrzehnte.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Der UNO-Hauptsitz in New York.
Heute treffen sich hier
Vertreter von 193 Mitgliedstaaten.
Es ist frühmorgens im Hotel Omni.
Cristina
kontrolliert nochmals den Ablauf,
für den sie
wochenlang gearbeitet hat.
Heute ist die grosse Eröffnung
der Generaldebatte.
Der Bundespräsident wird
heute Nachmittag seine Rede halten.
Jetzt kommen sie dann gleich.
Jetzt kommen sie dann gleich, viel-
leicht ist das gerade nicht so ...
Morgen.
- Guten Morgen.
Quelqu'un qui l'a oublie.
Neben Alain Berset sprechen
140 Staats- und Regierungschefs
an der UNO-Vollversammlung.
Der Rest ist streng vertraulich.
Samira muss heute
einen Vortrag halten.
Sie war noch nie in der neuen
Residenz der Schweizer Botschaft.
Im Vortrag geht es
um verantwortungsvolles Wirtschaften.
Eingeladen sind Chefs
von Schweizer Firmen in Kairo.
Es ist kein Thema,
in dem ich mich extrem gut auskenne.
Das kann im Alltag einer Diplomatin
durchaus vorkommen.
Und noch immer
muss sich Samira besonders beweisen.
Schon in einer Woche
ist die Abschlussprüfung.
Im Praktikum steht man
eigentlich immer unter Beobachtung.
Das ist schon
ein zusätzliches Element, das ...
Grundsätzlich will man ja sowieso,
dass alles gut läuft,
aber so halt noch etwas mehr.
Noch eine halbe Stunde bis zum Beginn
des Wirtschaftstreffens.
Aber dann geht etwas schief.
Here.
- Ah, okay. Uff!
Es fängt erst um halb an, aber
ich möchte etwas früher dort sein.
* Mohammed spricht arabisch. *
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Samiras Fahrer
möchte nicht gefilmt werden.
Und dann macht er
einen entscheidenden Fehler.
Er fragt ausgerechnet die Polizei
nach dem richtigen Weg und vergisst,
dass die Kamera im Auto läuft.
* Mohammed spricht arabisch. *
* Piepen *
Die Kamera ist für die Polizei ein
Problem, das könnte länger dauern.
Give me your passport!
Ich muss kurz die Fenster öffnen.
Jean-Baptiste
ist bald 15 Monate im Senegal.
In zwei Tagen
finden Präsidentschaftswahlen statt.
Manu, ca va assez vite,
on va le commander.
Excellent, a tout a l'heure, merci.
(Lachend)
Das kann noch ein bisschen dauern.
Ich fahre zu einem grossen Hotel,
um ein Briefing ...
Moment mal!
Bonjour, monsieur.
Ca va? Ca va bien?
Jean-Baptiste
hat eine wichtige Aufgabe.
Er ist offizieller Wahlbeobachter.
Es ist voll.
Dafür muss er
an einen Informationsanlass der EU.
Nichts ... Hey, warte mal!
Der letzte Platz.
Was an diesem Treffen passiert,
ist streng geheim.
Filmen ist darum verboten.
Der Transfer zum UNO-Hauptgebäude -
Cristina ist immer mittendrin.
Sie ist dafür verantwortlich,
dass der Bundespräsident zur
richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort ist.
Bisher ist alles
sehr gut aufgegangen.
Wir haben auch etwas Freiräume
eingeplant, weil wir wussten,
dass die Reden
länger als 15 Min. dauern können.
Bis jetzt ist alles gut.
Ein Bundespräsident
auf dem Trottoir,
das Bild ging um die Welt.
Vorbereitet hat sich Alain Berset
hier auf die UNO-Generalversammlung.
Angereist ist auch der Schweizer
Aussenminister Ignazio Cassis.
Während der Rede
von Bundespräsident Alain Berset
muss Cristina
den Teleprompter bedienen.
Ich war in der Teleprompter-Kabine.
Man sieht
den Text der Rede durchlaufen.
Und oben sieht man sein Bild.
Seine Rede war grossartig -
inhaltlich
und auch wie er gesprochen hat.
Die grösste Herausforderung
ist die intellektuelle Neugier,
die perpetuelle,
die ewige intellektuelle Neugier,
sich alle vier Jahre mit völlig
neuen Themen auseinanderzusetzen,
mit fremden Kulturen,
mit fremden Sichtweisen.
Und man darf sich nie verschliessen
und die Meinung vertreten:
"Wir wissen es ja besser."
* Hupen *
In Kairo rollt es wieder.
Wir steckten 20 Min. fest,
jetzt wird alles etwas hektischer.
Ah, oi, oi.
Man sieht absolut gar nichts.
Das ist echt schräg.
Das ist wegen des Stuhls.
- Ah, ich verstehe.
Und dann kommt
auch noch der Botschafter.
Vorher ging's -
jetzt muss ich noch kurz schauen ...
Warum ist es nicht mehr verbunden?
Irgendwie ist es
nicht mehr verbunden.
Das ist schon mal nicht schlecht.
Uff!
Please, please.
Open the ... Open the way.
Es sind wichtige Herren anwesend,
die Chefs grosser Schweizer Firmen.
Ihnen muss Samira erzählen,
was verantwortungsvolle
Geschäftsführung bedeutet
und warum das wichtig ist.
Thank you very much, Ambassador.
Und dann wird sie
schon fast etwas undiplomatisch.
(Alle) Thank you.
* Applaus *
Ich bin gespannt auf die Rück-
meldungen der Wirtschaftsvertreter.
Aber so far so good.
Thank you very much.
Darauf
achte ich grundsätzlich immer,
nicht nur im Rahmen
von Wirtschaftstreffen,
wie die Repräsentation ist und
wie viele Frauen am Tisch sitzen.
Ich bin mir durchaus bewusst,
dass ich die Schweizer Bevölkerung
repräsentiere.
Deshalb finde ich es
eben auch wichtig,
dass die Aussenpolitik auch die
Schweizer Bevölkerung reflektiert.
Ich finde es deshalb auch schön,
dass immer mehr Frauen
in der Diplomatie arbeiten.
Das kommt mit Verantwortung.
Tres bien.
- Merci. - Merci beaucoup.
Sonntagmorgen in New York.
Cristina hat ihre Arbeitskollegen zum
Brunch bei sich zu Hause eingeladen.
Möchte jemand noch etwa Quiche?
Sehr gerne. - Danke schön.
- Danke vielmals. - Merci.
Guten Appetit!
- Guten Appetit! - Danke vielmals.
Ah, du hast deinen Kaffee dort.
Valerie, willst du Kaffee oder Tee?
Ist gut für den Moment.
Vielleicht später einen Tee.
Merci.
Cristinas Gäste sind alle Schweizer.
Und alle arbeiten
bei der Schweizer Mission.
Freundschaften mit Amerikanern
entstanden keine.
Am Anfang ist es einfach,
die ersten Kontakte.
Aber diese zu vertiefen,
ist jeweils schwierig.
Wegen der Zeit,
weil alle so beschäftigt sind.
Viele Amerikaner
sind eher oberflächlich.
Gut, dass du Amerikaner gesagt hast.
Ich bin glücklich mit meinem Umfeld,
aber da sind keine Amerikaner.
Darf ich ein Ei haben?
- Klar.
Möchte jemand wie an Ostern
sein Ei gegen meines schlagen?
So zusammenstossen.
- Das ist aber gefährlich.
Im Moment ist gut.
Ich nehme nachher noch.
Ich reiche es dir rüber.
Hast du deinen Flug schon gebucht?
Den Flug habe ich ...
Geplant ist es.
Ich gehe mit Freunden
über Neujahr in den Oman.
Wow, ich liebe den Oman!
So schön!
Du bist Krisenmanager.
Und jetzt wird die Welt
spielerisch von Seuchen befreit.
Ich erkläre es später,
zuerst aber das Setup.
Hier sind
die verschiedenen Seuchenwürfel.
Ich bin ein Quarantänenspezialist.
Diplomaten sind zeitlebens
auf der ganzen Welt unterwegs,
weit weg von der Schweiz.
Beim Spielen kommt die Gruppe
auf das Thema Heimat zu sprechen.
Um mich zu Hause zu fühlen,
um mich hier wohlzufühlen,
sind mir kleine Dinge wichtig.
Ich konnte keine Möbel
oder ähnliche Dinge mitnehmen.
Ich nahm stattdessen
eine eigene Tasse mit.
Oder z.B. ein eigenes Badetuch,
damit ich nicht nur
die weissen von hier benutzen muss.
Damit ich nicht das Gefühl habe,
in einem Hotel zu wohnen.
Es sind kleine Dinge.
Man kann quasi im Koffer
ein Stück Heimat mitnehmen,
damit man sich
schneller einleben kann.
Das ist so heimelig.
Ich musste
farbige Küchentücher kaufen,
denn ich habe zu Hause
verschiedene Küchentücher.
Da es hier nur weisse hatte,
ging ich am ersten Wochenende
farbige Küchentücher kaufen.
# We need each other.
Wau-Wau.
- Wau-Wau.
(Samira) Hast du einen Hund gesehen?
Samira arbeitet
in ihrer Ausbildung 100 % -
für die Familie nicht immer einfach.
Manchmal merke ich schon,
dass das Gleichgewicht
recht zerbrechlich ist.
Wenn mit ihr etwas nicht gut ist,
mache ich mir schon Sorgen.
Alani, nein, nein!
Ah!
* Edgar lacht. *
Nach Argentinien, wo alte,
unschöne Erinnerungen wach werden.
Das Land am Rio de la Plata steckt
wie vor rund 20 Jahren schon einmal
in einer gefährlichen Währungskrise.
Auch bei Jonas in Buenos Aires
dreht sich darum jetzt
vieles um die Wirtschaftskrise.
Es gibt viele Demonstrationen.
Sie gehören hier
schon fast zum Alltag.
Die meisten Themen
betreffen die Wirtschaft,
den Internationalen Währungsfonds,
der Argentinien
einen Kredit gewährte.
Jonas hat jetzt die Aufgabe,
für die Regierung in Bern einen
politischen Bericht zu verfassen.
Die hiesigen Geschehnisse haben
auch Auswirkungen auf die Schweiz.
Unsere Botschaft
ist eine Art Antenne,
die die einzelnen Entwicklungen
detektiert.
Die argentinischen Medien
vermitteln meist nur eine Sicht,
aber sehr wichtig
ist die ganze Palette.
Buenos dias.
Darum besucht er ein Treffen von
Politikern und Wirtschaftsführern.
Insbesondere interessiert Jonas,
was diese Frau erzählt:
die Präsidentin der aussenpolitischen
Kommission Argentiniens.
Es gab soeben
eine sehr spannende Präsentation.
Ich würde sie gerne
zur Strategie befragen.
Darf ich noch eine Frage stellen?
- Natürlich.
Herzlichen Dank,
Frau Schmidt-Liermann.
Wo sehen Sie
das grösste Potenzial Argentiniens
für die nächsten zehn Jahre?
Ganz ehrlich: bei den Menschen.
Ich glaube,
Globalisierung, Multilateralismus
und Freihandelsabkommen sind gut,
wenn wir wirklich
an die Menschen denken
und wenn wir uns komplementieren.
Ich glaube, das ist wirklich gut,
aber wir müssen auch etwas
Barmherzigkeit an den Mann bringen.
Ganz herzlichen Dank.
Und schon kommen die Nächsten.
Muchas gracias por su tiempo.
... las relaciones
entre Brasil y Argentina.
Hola. Buenas tardes.
Die grösste Herausforderung ist,
dass man wirklich
relevante Informationen gewinnt.
Oft wird viel gesprochen,
aber wenig gesagt.
Es ist wichtig, dass man diese Leute
abholen und dazu bringen kann,
dass sie etwas Bedeutendes sagen,
das für mich auch relevant ist.
Ciao.
Muchas gracias. Que le vaya bien.
Muchas gracias.
- Por favor.
Con gusto.
Muchas gracias.
Präsidentschaftswahlen im Senegal.
Fast 7 Mio. Senegalesen
können heute ihre Stimme abgeben.
Favorit ist der aktuelle Präsident
Macky Sall.
Bonjour. Comment ca va?
Jean-Baptiste und seine
Arbeitskollegin von der Botschaft
sind als Wahlbeobachter im Einsatz.
Meine Wahlbeobachtererfahrung
beträgt vielleicht 15 Min.,
aber es gibt ganz, ganz viele Dinge.
Wir haben ein Formular mit Fragen,
das wir ausfüllen müssen.
"Ist das Material da?"
"Wer ist im Raum?"
"Wer darf den Raum
betreten oder nicht?"
Wir dürfen nie intervenieren,
wir müssen einfach beobachten.
Wir müssen auch aufpassen,
dass keine Polizei im Büro ist.
Denn das ist nicht erlaubt.
Aber schon im nächsten Wahllokal
stimmt etwas nicht so ganz.
Die sollten nicht hier drin sein.
Sie sollten sich ausserhalb
der Perimeter aufhalten.
Das gibt einen Rapport an die EU,
die die Wahlen überwacht.
Tres bien, oui.
Er sagte,
solange es nur am Anfang so war
und sie nicht die Büros betreten,
sei es nicht so schlimm.
In Senegal wird der alte Präsident
wohl auch der neue sein:
Macky Sall.
Der 57-Jährige
gilt als grosser Favorit.
Sall dürfte davon profitieren,
dass Senegal in den letzten Jahren
einen beachtlichen
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwung erlebte.
Bonne journee.
Sind wir vorhin mit dem Auto
nicht schon einmal hier gewesen?
Salut, ca va?
Ou est le bureau de vote?
C'est la, c'est la?
* Stimmengewirr, dynamische Musik *
Tu m'as dit, c'est quel bureau?
- 60-30.
C'est le bureau ...
Allo. Oui, c'est Jean-Baptiste.
A plus tard,
bonne suite, bonne suite.
Sorry.
Die Wahlen
sind natürlich die Krönung,
wenn man die ganze politische
Situation ein Jahr studiert hat
und man die Wahlbeobachtung
machen kann.
Wahnsinn.
Die Stimmen sind ausgezählt,
die Couverts mit den Resultaten
versiegelt.
Aber auch nach 13 Std.
ist der Tag noch nicht zu Ende.
* Gespieltes Weinen *
* Ächzen *
Jetzt müssen sie noch
für den Rapport zur Botschafterin.
Hallo, Chefin.
Ca va?
- Ca va?
Mort.
- Mort?
Ihr seht müde aus.
Voila. Oh, es windet etwas.
Oh, cool!
- Du kannst wählen.
So cool.
Oui, genau.
Cheers.
- Sante.
Ihr habt es verdient.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es euch ging,
aber ich habe
ein bisschen mitgefiebert.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie du es erlebt hast,
aber ich habe stets
auf die kleinen Dinge geachtet.
Es war nicht so, wie wenn man
die News oder Twitter studiert,
sondern: "Hat der
seinen Finger gerade in die ..."
Oder: "Wie viele gibt es da noch?"
Kleine Details, spannend.
Die Stimmung,
der Kontakt mit den Menschen,
das war ... wow!
In der Schweizer Botschaft
schreibt Jonas an seinem Bericht.
Mit allen Informationen,
die er gesammelt hat.
Als studierter Physiker
hat er als Diplomat
einen eher untypischen Hintergrund.
Ich konnte in dieser Zeit
wirklich sehr viel lernen.
Ich sehe das als einen Weg.
In der momentanen Phase
geht es ums Lernen, ums Aufnehmen.
In einigen Situationen
wurde ich ins kalte Wasser geworfen.
Am Anfang ist das nicht angenehm.
Aber mit der Zeit
gewöhnt man sich daran und weiss,
dass man notfalls
auch improvisieren kann.
Alleine in der grossen Stadt,
in einer Verhandlung auch
alleine die Schweiz vertreten -
das ist irgendwie alles ...
tut das irgendwie gut.
Diesmal bin ich überzeugt,
dass es wirklich passt.
Und dieses Gefühl, am richtigen Ort
zum richtigen Zeitpunkt zu sein,
ist einfach Wahnsinn.
Das ist wirklich
eine Erkenntnis dieses Jahres.
Ich war eigentlich nie
ein Selbstdarsteller.
Ich dachte immer,
wichtig sei schon der Inhalt.
Und ...
Ich denke, in gewissen Situationen
im Leben wäre es sicherlich gut,
wenn man sich selbst auf eine
bestimmte Art darstellen könnte.
Aber andererseits ist mir das
auch ein bisschen zu anstrengend.
Dann muss Papa
nicht alles alleine machen.
Dann muss er nicht alleine stossen,
wir sind auch starke Frauen.
Ich finde die diplomatische Karriere
nach wie vor extrem spannend.
Acht Monate in Kairo -
eigentlich unglaublich,
dass man so eine Chance bekommt.
Andererseits
muss man aber wirklich bereit sein,
auf viele Dinge zu verzichten.
Aber es gibt noch eine letzte Hürde.
In Bern findet heute
die grosse Abschlussprüfung statt.
Zwei Jahre Diplomatenausbildung,
der Concours diplomatique,
das alles könnte heute
ein abruptes Ende nehmen.
Ich bin schon etwas nervös.
Ich habe etwas vorbereitet.
Ich brauche es nicht -
es ist eher psychologisch.
Die Symbolik ist schon stark.
Bonjour. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
- Bonjour.
Der lang erwartete Moment.
Jetzt geht es darum,
sich etwas zu beruhigen,
um vor der Kommission
nicht allzu nervös zu wirken.
In der Kommission sitzen hochrangige
Diplomaten und Akademiker.
(Mann) Madame la Presidente.
Geht's gut?
Die Stagiaires haben eine Chance.
Wenn sie diese nicht packen,
ist es vorbei
mit der Diplomatenkarriere.
Die Personen,
die dem Departementschef
zur Aufnahme beantragt werden ...
Das ist für eine ganze Karriere,
für eine ganze Laufbahn.
Deshalb braucht es schon
eine strenge Beurteilung.
Es kann sich noch entscheiden.
Es ist ein letzter Kontrollgriff,
da man wirklich sicher sein will,
ob sie nach zwei Jahren Probezeit
die Bedingungen erfüllen.
Man hat 25 Min. Zeit,
um diese Fragen zu beantworten,
seinen Parcours,
diese zwei Jahre zu verteidigen.
Ich finde das schon krass.
Ah, da passiert was.
(Frau) Voila.
Salut.
- Merci.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ja, es ist vorbei.
Jetzt ist es endlich ...
endlich vorbei.
Merci.
Ich glaube: nicht schlecht.
Uff!
Es war gut.
Ich finde,
es war schon herausfordernd.
Also ... ja.
Die Kommissionsmitglieder wollen ja
ein wenig kritische Fragen stellen.
Es kamen sehr spannende Fragen auf,
bei denen man sich überlegen musste,
wie man es in den
letzten zwei Jahren erlebt hat.
"Was war die grösste Überraschung,
die Sie über sich selbst
im Senegal erfahren haben?"
Wow!
Ich hatte eigentlich keine Ahnung,
musste dabei etwas kreativ sein.
Es waren für mich
viele unerwartete Fragen.
Einer sagte ganz offen,
er sei mit meiner Antwort
nicht ganz einverstanden.
Dann stellte er
die Frage nochmals anders.
Ich mag kritische Fragen.
Denn auf solche Fragen
gibt es auch gute Antworten.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich alles gegeben habe.
Jetzt liegt es
nicht mehr in meinen Händen.
In wenigen Stunden
entscheidet die Kommission,
wer die Prüfung besteht
und wer Diplomatin oder Diplomat
werden kann.
Erst einmal gehe ich eine Glace
in der Gelateria di Berna essen,
die gleich bei mir um die Ecke ist.
Und danach
gehe ich wohl ein bisschen nähen.
Ich werde jetzt joggen gehen -
endlich.
Ich habe das so vermisst.
Ich konnte im Senegal
nicht joggen gehen,
weil die Luftverschmutzung
so schlimm war.
Jetzt endlich,
nach anderthalb Jahren,
kann ich an der Aare joggen gehen.
Ich freue mich wahnsinnig darauf.
In Bern fallen jetzt Entscheidungen.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Hoi.
Hallo, Simone.
Wirklich?
Ah, cool.
Merci vielmals, megacool!
Ja! Ja!
Ja!
Ich freue mich sehr.
Merci viel, viel mal.
Ich freue mich so.
Perfekt. Cool. Merci vielmals.
Juhu!
Merci. Tschau, tschau.
Yes!
Yeah!
So schön. Ich bin so glücklich.
Merci viel, viel mal, Simone.
C'est bon.
- Yes.
It's great.
- Gosh!
Crazy.
Okay, ähm ...
Alex und Samira haben also bestanden.
Aber wie erging es den anderen drei?
* Feierliche Streichmusik *
Ja, die Leute sollen ...
Diplomübergabe vom Aussenminister
Ignazio Cassis höchstpersönlich.
Et le lettre dans votre main.
Belina.
- Vielen Dank.
Seien Sie ganz herzlich willkommen!
Cizero reicht.
- Cizero reicht.
Frau Verones, seien Sie
herzlich willkommen im EDA
und im diplomatischen Corps.
- Danke schön.
Die Schweiz hat zwölf
neue Diplomatinnen und Diplomaten.
C'est bon comme ca?
* Fröhlicher Popsong:
"There Is A Party" von DJ BoBo *
# There' s a party, don't you know
today there is a party.
Ist der Ball doch noch hier?
Ja?
- Ah, das ist dein Platz. Gut.
Und das finden wir ... skandalös.
Oh my God!
"Mehr nach hinten", sagte sie.
So etwas fragt man nicht.
Noch einmal, sorry.
Noch einmal.
Ta-ta-ta-ta-ta ...
Grundgütiger!
Ich lasse das Horn und die Flügel
weg und ändere den Schwanz.
Aber sonst
ähnelt es stark einem Zebra.
Ah!